hey everyone I'm Abbi short welcome to
Abby's kitchen today I partnered up with
my friends and Metamucil who sponsored
this video to share free of my favorite
easy snacks for keeping my hunger
monster at bay and trust me mine not
pretty now I don't know about you but I
think planning healthy snacks is the key
to preventing those hangry situations
where I legit cannot get food into my
mouth fast enough so for that reason I
always keep foods on hand have one or
more hunger pressing compounds like fat
fiber and protein so today i've
incorporated all of these is free easy
and fast ideas they'll help satisfy your
craving less skewness first up my cream
school community in a blender I combine
frozen bananas fresh oranges high
protein Greek yogurt and my secret
ingredient Metamucil Smita appetite
control for those of us who find it hard
to get our 25 to 38 shake 18 grams of
fiber each day this is an easy way to
get 6 grams in just 2 teaspoons
not only does fiber helps keep us
satiated and fuller longer it's also
important for digestive health heart
health and regularity plus it gives a
smoothie a yummy sicknesses to see that
is super satisfying and tasty depending
on how you like your smoothie
I recommend sending it out with a little
bit of unsweetened vanilla almond milk
next my protein guacamole this recipe
starts with your yogurt which is nice
landok yogurt I am totally obsessed with
because it's got more proteins in Greek
and it's thicker and less astringent I
mean one cup has a whopping 25 gram so
to a bowl I'm explain secure yogurt with
some rice smashed avocado and lime juice
until combined
then I add in some diced tomatoes
jalapenos and fresh cilantro
serve it up with fresh cut veggies for
dipping and enjoy
finally my power icecream
this starts for some cars cheese which
packs an impressive 25 grams of protein
per cup so in a blender I puree plain
unsweetened cottage cheese with some
frozen strawberries so it turns into a
creamy sweet Froyo texture you can add
honey or maple syrup to taste but I
usually find this perfectly sweet just
as is then I pop it into the freezer
until it solidifies for about an hour
and finish it off with a drizzle of
almond butter and some crushed toasted
on it so there you have it three easy
nourishing snack ideas help get you to
your next meal without the hangry
meltdown I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
what kind of snacks keep you guys
satisfied until you get your next meal
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen